speaker danien brinkley says he's
already seen the other side at least
three times
he spoke to the i-team's george knapp
i have been dead so many times it's like
a comedy routine
okay i mean when you get to talking
about being dead george i got a down
pat in 1975 a macho former star
athlete and u.s marine named danien
brinkley a self-described brawler
and redneck had a life-changing
life-ending experience
when a bolt of lightning slammed through
a phone line and into his skull
it melted the foam it went into the side
of my head above my ear
it went down my spine it welded the
nails of the heels of my shoes to the
floor
it threw me up in the air i see the
ceiling it slams me back down
a ball of fire comes through the room
and blinds me
i am burning i am on fire i am paralyzed
brinkley says he left his body floated
along with the ambulance as it raced to
a hospital
and watched from above as doctors
declared him dead
28 minutes later he says he awoke in the
hospital morgue
during the interim his consciousness
traveled through a tunnel
where he encountered a spiritual being
of light and
underwent a grueling replay of his
entire life
then in a flash he was back in his
severely injured body
it took him two years to be able to walk
again he told
few people what had happened and not
even his family believed him
but in the same year as the lightning
bolt incident a georgia physician dr
raymond moody wrote a book life after
life and coined the term
near-death experience or nde dr moody in
his book were pilloried by medical
colleagues
and by 1977 moody was broke and
despondent and ready to quit
former bully danien brinkley met moody
and became his staunchest defender
in 1989 during open heart surgery
brinkley died again
and once again visited what he perceived
to be the afterlife
he wrote a book saved by the light which
became a runaway bestseller
skeptics and debunkers came after him
disputing
biographical details and arguing that
ndes happen because the brain
is dying not because people are visiting
heaven brinkley who later had yet
another nde during brain surgery says
he's happy to take on all comers
including religious leaders
about what happens to us when we die if
i didn't go to hell
in the last four journeys nobody's going
to hell
okay so when you learn you don't die
when you learn your spiritual being and
you're not going to go to hell
that's enough to inspire you to change
brinkley put his beliefs into action he
spent tens of thousands of hours at the
bedsides of the dying
personally witnessed more than two
thousand people as they passed on
and created a program called the
twilight brigade which works with the va
to try to ensure that no military
veteran should
die alone a defiant brinkley hobbled by
a lifetime of serious injuries
knows he's helped thousands of people
who are facing death
whether science or religion believe him
or not why i
do these talks george is because nobody
dies
it never happens it's not
a part of the nature of reality
it's not george knapp 8 news now
tomorrow we will put up the full
interview with danien brinkley on our
mystery wire website along with
related links as well as additional
materials